[Music]
i'm excited to talk about
uh making powerpoint presentations with
our markdown today this is a project
that
has been we've been working on for a
while now and it's
uh nice to finally present some of the
material
so you're probably wondering why would
you want to create a powerpoint
presentation
from our markdown
well there's a number of reasons but i'm
going to point out a few
so one reason is that everyone knows
powerpoint
it's a standard communication tool
especially used in business people learn
to speak the language of powerpoint and
the
the fact of the matter is it's very
useful because it works it's very
flexible
you can make slides fast and everyone
has personal experience with it
some people love it some people not so
much but everyone has an opinion on it
because we've all touched this tool
but your work of course is coded in r
and that's because your code is your
product
so your output is a manifestation of
your code so plots tables model
output that's all coming from your code
well that's where our markdown becomes
very useful our markdown makes your work
reproducible you can leave text and code
to produce
elegantly formatted output you can use
things like our notebooks
for doing interactive analyses our
markdown if you haven't used it is will
allow you to
create a number of different output
types reports
apps dashboards html docs pdfs word
documents
but not powerpoint not until now
so now you can make powerpoint
presentations with our markdown
as of uh rstudio version 1.2 you can
render powerpoint presentations from the
ide
this combines two great things
powerpoint and our markdown
you can think of it as the reese's
peanut butter cup of presentation
software
i'm not sure which one's the chocolate
which one's the peanut butter but you
can tell i put this together during
uh the halloween time period
so let me show you a quick demo of doing
powerpoint presentations with rstudio
so this is the rstudio preview version
1.2 if i go up to file
new file bar markdown
and then i choose presentation
down at the bottom i have an option to
do powerpoint
i click ok and this is an our markdown
document again if you've never seen our
markdown it's going to
it will contain the pros some narrative
plus some r code chunks some things
about r that you might want to include
in your document
and then the output type here is
powerpoint presentation
and the way you create the powerpoint
presentations is you hit this knit
button
when i hit this i'll give it a name
and it generates a powerpoint uh deck
with the content some bullets
some r code output and a nice little
plot
right now if you don't want to use the r
studio ide that's fine
you don't have to use r studio ide you
can always render this
programmatically this all works with
open source software
you can do this inside of an r console
type in
render give it the name and the output
format and that will also
generate the powerpoint output
all right so some of the benefits of
using our markdown here
well in this book r for data science
there's this lovely chapter at the end
of this book if you haven't seen it i
recommend that you
you read it it's about our mark down
about communicating
insights um to decision makers
and it makes the point that our market
is a great way to influence
other people in your organization and
other people that will be making
decisions
based on the work that you do in your
data science
will allow you to do better data science
because you'll be collaborating with
other data scientists
who are able to read your code
understand your code and reproduce your
code
and it gives you this nice environment
in which you can do data science
when you put your narrative together
with the code and the output into a
single document i would argue through
personal experience that
you do better data science it allows you
to think more clearly
and understand why you're doing what
you're doing
from a presentation standpoint with
powerpoint i think one of the big
takeaways here is that you're just going
to spend a lot less time iterating on
presentation slides and a lot more time
doing what you do best
which is data science
all right so how does it work
well you write your code in our markdown
format
and then you knit the code with the
knitter package
and what knitter does is it takes your r
markdown code
and it converts it into a
markdown format and markdown format is a
is a universal format
that can be put into this other system
called pandoc
and pandoc is what actually converts the
markdown document
into powerpoint now all of this is
already bundled into the ide so it's
it's seamless but this is what's
happening under the covers
so i want to focus on this pandock piece
for a second
what is what what is pandoc well pandoc
is the open source software that
converts files from one format into
another you can think of it as a swiss
army knife
and powerpoint output was added uh to
pandock and padlock version two
the initial release was in december 2017
and then there was a number of
progressive updates that happened at the
beginning of this year to
allow you to create these uh this
powerpoint output
and pandoc is bundled into the rstudio
ide
and the rstudio ide version 1.2 has
the ability to create powerpoint
documents and our studio connect as a
version 1.6.4 which came out a
few months ago that also has the ability
to
support powerpoint documents now a lot
of this work
here with pandoc was done by a
developer a haskell developer pandox
written haskell
um and he uh and he works out of
um he's a professor at johns hopkins
university
and his name is jesse rosenthal and
jesse is actually on the call today so
it's great to have him here and joining
the webinar but
most of this development work was that
allows us to
convert documents into powerpoint was
done by jesse
our markdown is not the only way to do
document conversion into powerpoint
you have these other r packages that you
might have used
and these are great r packages i've used
some of them um
they allow you to have fine-grained
control over what happens on those
slides
and they some of these will have
features that aren't available in the
markdown
um format conversion format
so these packages are still relevant you
might still find these very useful
let's talk about use cases for
creating powerpoint presentations from
our markdown
the first one is to render the
presentation and then customize the
presentation
and and that's probably going to be a
very common use case
for your powerpoint slides you're going
to output the text the tables and the
plots the powerpoint and you're going to
modify these or copy these
into your final presentation i'll give
you an example
this is a notebook that analyzes
bank data and in the course of this
analysis i create a whole bunch of
visualizations
that are interesting and normally what i
would do
with these visualizations is i would
take these
and i'd copy these one at a time into
my powerpoint presentation my powerpoint
presentation would become a mess
and then i'd lose track of which ones
are which and i'd have to go back and up
when i go back to update my analysis
then things become
out of sync be much better just to be
able to render all the slides
in one shot from this notebook and
that's what
what you can do with the powerpoint up
output
so i come up here and say uh
knit this presentation this will go
through and
spin up a new r session run all of the r
code
through that session and then generate a
powerpoint presentation
okay so here's the slides you can see
that i've got my
narrative again and then i've got some
graphs here
and i can take these graphs and i can
copy these into my final presentation
i've got a table and that's really great
too
right and i can um if i if i don't like
the order here i can just move these
around if i need to
if i don't like if i want to change the
background um change my template
i can do that as well
you know choose a different template
if i'm not happy with the
table the table renders as a powerpoint
table so i can go ahead and change that
table design
and i can and at this and i can come in
here and say
you know i've got more than one data
source i've got data sources
i'm going to change that and now i've
really broken the reproducibility
paradigm right
i've actually gone through and made some
changes and now if i go back and re
do the slides you have to do those again
but i'd argue that you're
much better off because you can produce
a lot of these
at the same time and you can keep them
anchored to that our markdown document
that explains what you're what you're
doing
so we think this will be a pretty common
use case for taking slides and then
manipulating them people like to
customize their powerpoint presentations
and chances are your slides are going to
be one part of a
larger presentation that ends up getting
delivered
to the executive or the client or
whoever you're trying
to communicate with and that will work
great in this workflow
the other use case is to publish to
rstudio connect
what is rstudio connect it's a
publishing platform for r
it runs your r code and allows you to
share your shiny apps
our markdown reports and much much more
so in this use case what you're going to
do is you're going to output the entire
presentation
with with our markdown and then you're
going to render
updates programmatically on a schedule
and then you'll distribute those
powerpoint presentations by email and
you can even design them to accept
user inputs so this is a little bit
easier to show
than to explain
here's another presentation that i'm
using it's the stock
data and this is a parametrized our
markdown document and if you haven't
seen parameterized
or markdown before they're extremely
powerful you set up parameters here
and then inputs here this is going to be
the
tesla stock ticker symbol and if i want
to call that in my r markdown document
i just use param string symbol so these
become very useful in their own right
even regardless of
how you're you know accepting user
inputs or what output formats
you're using parameterizer markdown
parameterization
is extremely powerful in our markdown
documents but here what i can do is i
can say
i'm going to knit this thing i'll go
ahead and knit it with parameters
and i'll choose like uh the ibm report i
guess right i'll knit this document
great now i have a document for the ibm
candlestick chart and uh this is what i
want but i can't anticipate
everybody's needs here with um
all of the different stock tickers that
they might
need no nor am i able to automate this
every day you know i don't have the
ability to update this every day i have
to be able to
automate it with the system so i want to
make sure that this report gets
generated daily and sent out to the
people
that are interested in it so what i do
is i
publish the star studio connect and i
can do that with this publish button
and choose rcu connect and this is what
rcu connect looks like
here's the default report it's going to
be the tesla report
if i want to change the report
ticker i can go in here and i can say i
want to change
ibm right and you run that report i'm
not going to run the report because i've
already done it for you
it's right here and then if i want to i
can go ahead and email this report to
myself right
or i can come in here and i can schedule
this report
to run every day and then send me an
email when it's complete and i can add
more people to this report
and that what that report looks like is
if i go to my inbox
you can see that i just got the report
it's got this nice
graphic here that tells me that ibm
closed at 1203
and i come down here to the end and i
can see that i've attached
the powerpoint presentation to the email
and again this is going to be the
updated report that i just ran
so you can see that this would be a very
useful way to
communicate your insights with a lot of
people who
prefer to get their information by email
and powerpoint i personally know a lot
of people in that boat that would like
to get their information
communicated to them and um emailing
powerpoint
perhaps you do as well um the nice thing
here is that
you only have to write the code once and
then our studio connect can handle
the the scheduling and the distribution
and accept the user inputs
systematically
so those are some use cases let's talk
about features
so the powerpoint output
accepts most of the markdown features
that are supported in other document
formats
for example
inline formatting is supported so this
is what the nine formatting looks like
in your code and this is how it gets
rendered into powerpoint
supports lists
the tech so if you're putting in math
equations
hyperlinks of course
block quotes
images from the web this went out and
snagged an image from the web and then
put it into my slide
images from file this actually took an
image from a file and put it to my slide
you can add captions to images
you can add a link to caption to the
image
or you can link the image in this case
what happens is if i click this image
this will take me to the r for data
science page
sports tables so you write your tables
and mark down code that looks like this
and they get rendered like this notice
there's a caption down here
it also supports these really nifty
features like
columns so columns are great what you do
here is you create
uh these uh this fence this is called a
fence
div and you put all the contents for the
first column here
and you put all the contents for the
second column here
and then it will show up in your two
column layout your two
it's called the two content layout it's
two columns
and two contents and two columns
it supports speaker notes speaker notes
are very useful
again you put a fence div here and you
can put the speaker notes
they'll render in the presentation
and templates the templates become very
useful also and i'll be talking about
that a little bit later
and of course this translation supports
our code that's the whole point of this
right you want to be able to put our
code into your markdown documents
what kind of r code does it support well
any of the r code that's in your arc
code chunks
and that typically typically is going to
look like code and your code
is gets highlighted the syntax of your
code gets highlighted
in the output but automatically
tables so if you call the cable function
which is
in knitter it will create a table in
powerpoint
ggplot or any other visualization that
will render that image
on a content slide
and if you do something interactive like
uh
in html widgets here i'm using digraphs
the rendering process will go if you
have installed the webshop package
the rendering process will go and grab a
web screenshot
of your interactive visualization
and include it in your powerpoint
presentation
and finally shiny how do you include
shiny in your
powerpoint presentations chinese
interactive powerpoint presentations are
static
so obviously you can't put shiny inside
of powerpoint that would be
ridiculous what you're going to do
instead is you're going to
put a static image of your shiny
application
on your slide and then link that to your
shiny application
which will be hosted in shiny apps io
rstudio
connect or shiny server
so i will show you an example
in the course of my analysis i created
this shiny application
it's a customer tracker app the nice
thing about this is it allows me to
drill down
on into uh subgroups and other segments
but obviously i can't put all of those
segments or
groups into a powerpoint presentation
so what do i do
i go back to the code and i include this
line
include app and i put the url for that
application
into my presentation
then when i knit this process it's going
to go and take a screenshot
of that shiny application and put it
back into my presentation
for example this deck shows
the total segment and the total group
gives me some high level results
and some details and then it says
use the shiny app to explore other
segments and groups
and this image here is a linked image
i can click on this image and it
seemed to have lost my powerpoint
presentation
let's try that again
all right so when i click on this image
this will take me back to my shiny
application
and this shiny this will allow your
views your viewers
to interact with your application
choose a subgroup and i've even put a
download link here to take a snapshot of
this report
that is formatted in excel and allows
you to see
the report that you've dug into gives
you all the data to do
cross tabs if you want to do that but
what i've done here is i've
tied powerpoint pre a powerpoint
presentation
an excel output and a shiny application
and put them all on top of the same
yeah the same code base
all right so let's talk about resources
what what resources are available
the first place to go to get help would
probably be our markdown.ourstudio.com
that's our website about our markdown
there's also a new book that's out
called our markdown the definitive guide
it gives you
information about all the our um all of
the output types and
everything that you'd want to know about
our markdown
i've created a getting started page and
a troubleshooting page
for powerpoint output specifically so i
recommend taking a look at those
if you have specific questions about
your work then
community.rtstudio.com is a great place
to connect with other people
and then if you do find any issues
please let us know by submitting issues
to the our markdown
github repo
i want to address some frequently asked
questions there's a
question about getting started um about
using templates
and presentations that we get frequently
so this is the getting started page we
come down here to
templates you can see that the um
the way you set up a template is with
this reference dock
and the template supports uh four of
the many layouts that are in our studio
are in a
powerpoint template these are the
layouts that you want
to include in your template
for our markdown documents the first one
is
the title layout so this will give you
the title and the subtitle
on this slide the next one is the
section header
and the section header will only render
the content
we'll render i'm sorry we'll only render
the header
and not the content the title and
content
slide which you typically think of as
the main slide
and then the two content layout which
allows you to do
columns now layouts are important
because
markdown doesn't allow you to
programmatically change
the the design or
size of your of your presentation so
what it does is it actually pandock
actually ships with a 4x3
vanilla template
that is used to render presentations by
default
so if you want to use like a wide screen
format
you're going to have to create a
widescreen template and include that as
a
custom template here in your reference
dock if you want to change the
background
or if you want to change the layout the
placeholders
in any way that's all going to happen
with the template
which okay
the next thing i want to talk about is
structuring the presentation
so powerpoint present this gets a little
detailed but
i think it's important to go through
powerpoint presentations
have a hierarchy of title section and
content
uh whereas markdown documents have a
hierarchy of
headers and contents so in order for the
powerpoint presentation
to get structured pandoc has to
determine which markdown header level
should be used for the powerpoint slide
level so for example
and this are marked in this markdown
document
you have a hierarchy of headers that go
from one
to five and this
header is the one that pandock is going
to use
as the slide level by default and it's
going to use it
as a slide level because
it's the first slide that has content
associated with it
so everything that gets rendered above
this is going to be turned into sections
section slides and everything below this
is going to be turned into sub headers
on the content slide now if you didn't
want this to be the content slide and
you wanted this to be
the the slide level you would change
slide level to 2
because 2 would match would match up to
the two hashtags on
this our markdown section header
okay so you probably don't have to worry
too much about this because
the defaults should work well for you in
most cases
if you want to avoid this issue
altogether
you can just use the same level header
for
everything and then everything will be
rendered as content slides
the way that the slides get broken up
follows these five rules i'm not going
to go through all these right now
but just know that um there is a way to
that that they get rendered and there's
an easy way to find out what those rules
are
just go to the getting started page and
it will explain it
all right so troubleshooting what types
of issues might you expect to run into
well some of the common things that we
see
is that uh the powerpoint presentation
gets broken
and you get a message that says that it
needs to be repaired
or removed or you get this weird one
which doesn't even give you anything at
all
and typically the reason for these
errors
is that the markdown code that you wrote
looks
something like this where everything is
condensed together
and when you write our when you write
markdown code you need to put spaces
in between the content the title and the
speaker notes and if you go and put
those
spaces back in and then restart our
uh powerpoint powerpoint's an old
program
needs to be restarted every time you get
into this weird state
if you go back and put the spaces in
restart powerpoint
um this should render more successfully
so that would be the first thing to try
how do i put an image in a text on the
same slide there's
there's two ways to put images and text
on the same slide
one is to use captions and if you use a
caption
in markdown it's going to look something
like this and if you use caption
in a code junk it's going to look
something like this
and then and you can write very long
captions here so this this is actually a
very
workable solution probably the the
easiest solution
to your code if you
and tables support captions as well you
have to use table caption on those
so the other way to do it is to use
columns and this uses the two content
layout
that you can put your text on one side
and your image on the other side
you could actually add a caption to this
image as well
so um this is a great way to
separate text and columns you could put
images on both
columns or an image on this side and
text on the other side
but then the next question of course is
well how do i control the placement of
images and text
and there is no way to do that
programmatically
um you have to do that with the
templates as i mentioned
earlier so here what i've done is i've
taken the two content
uh layout in my template and i've
stacked
one of the content play placeholders on
top of the other one
and it renders quite nicely right allows
me to put an image
on the bottom and text on the top the
only issue here is that you only get one
of these so
you have to stick with this layout
throughout your presentation
but this will work really nicely for um
for this layout if you need more
programmatic control
then you're probably going to be in the
situation where you need one of those r
packages we talked about earlier
how do i control the size of an image
well you can't
pandock automatically resizes images to
fit a placeholder
currently it's not possible to
programmatically change the image size
how do i create a build slide build
slides are very useful currently that's
not supported
so you can't do a build slide today
that's that's where you click the button
and
bullet point one two three show up in
order how do i render
a presentation programmatically we
talked about that already
through the render command and how do i
check my markdown code so sometimes it's
useful to check your markdown code
if you're trying to debug your rendering
process and the way you do that is you
use the clean equals false option and
that will
output the markdown file that gets
generated in the rendering process you
can open that up and
see if it's creating the markdown that
you intended to
to create
so all of the things that you saw today
were generated
in our markdown with the powerpoint
output including this presentation that
you're looking at today this was also
generated
from an our markdown document and all of
that is stored in a github repo
under the solange uh category uh
as a with uh and it's called powerpoint
i've included a number of vignettes in
here as well that i didn't show today
but are very useful in understanding how
these features work
i if you're interested in looking at
that that's you can download the
github repo today and try it out but
make sure that you
install rstudio version 1.2
preview and you can get there by
googling our studio preview
downloading the latest copy and trying
this out today
so i hope you have a lot of fun making
powerpoint presentations with
our markdown and uh thank you very much
for the time
i'll uh let me toggle over and take some
questions now
all right what customizations of
powerpoint
can you do within r
i think the best can you do any
customizations
on tables yeah so so that's all going to
be dictated
i think the question is like yeah can i
programmatically change
the table color or shape or size
all of that is going to be dictated by
the
templates so you're going to want to
define all of that in the template so if
you want to change like
the link color for example you'll change
the color of the link
in the template and then pandock will
automatically
render those links in that color
are those rmd codes embedded
in the powerpoint file
the rmd codes embedded in the powerpoint
file
if i understand correctly you're talking
about the syntax head
and how the code is being out
outputted to the powerpoint file that's
in the echo
but i'm a little confused about this
question because you won't actually have
code in the powerpoint that there's no
code that's going to run in the
powerpoint file right you're just going
to echo the code
into the powerpoint slides and your and
pandoc is going to
[Music]
do the syntax highlighting for you i
hope that answers the question if not
let me know
can you trigger an email based on output
in our connect so the emails are
you can manually email yourself let me
just
show this again
so the way you email in powerpoint is
you can email
yourself here that's one way to email
the other way to email is to send an
email
after it has been rendered
after it's been completed after it's
completed the schedule
so that's the way so you can basically
you cannot you can send emails either on
demand or programmatically
good question does it support
bibtex citations as footnote
of the slide so the um i don't think
i've tried that
that's a good question um i haven't
tried that
there are some footnotes that belong to
the
layouts and you might have seen that in
the presentation
so i would have to see if the layouts
actually supported
that footnote regarding my shiny
question
what i'm envisioning is a button in my
shiny app
that an end user can press that will
output a powerpoint
which will contain an image of the graph
that the end user has customized yeah so
so
so here's the the rule of thumb with
shiny you can do anything with shiny
right i mean it's it's it's basically
unbounded so if you want to have a shiny
application
that renders a powerpoint presentation
from a button press
and then allows you to download that or
even pipe that to some other system
you you can do all of that and you might
use an r package to render that
powerpoint presentation or you might use
our markdown file to render that
presentation it's really up to you to
determine how to do that but if you use
the r markdown
format you'll want to use that render
command that we showed you
to you know generate that the powerpoint
output
do custom templates need to be stored
someplace specific
no you can reference them from any
location in the yamo header
does it matter if you create the
powerpoint on windows laptop
or mac will uh the images work
if you open the powerpoint and the other
os
later on yeah the cross platform will
work just fine
do these templates allow for background
images yes you can put images on there
on the template there that that will
work
can you custom can use a custom layout
that is not
one of the four mentioned above no you
have to use those four layouts that are
mentioned in the documentation
any idea when this will be released for
real and not in the preview
we don't have uh i don't i do not have a
release date for
our studio 1.2 for you today but
please keep track of our blog you'll see
that there's lots of updates that are
coming out we're very excited
about the next release can you create a
powerpoint graph with the data behind it
so someone else can modify the graph
in powerpoint directly
no that is not a feature that is
supported today
what about font size or type of font
again all controlled
from the template i'm just going to
pause here on some of these questions
because there are a lot of questions
that
that are stating i like to have fine
grained control over my powerpoint
presentations and if you
really want fine grain control you
should either use one of those r
packages
and code those up explicitly or you
should
do the custom work that would be my
recommendation
how can i choose different slide
packages in r
such as i o slides
so if you want to do different
slides i want to i think this is the
question if you come up here
and do new file our markdown
presentation you can see here's here's i
o slides
right and sliding beamer and this and we
actually support more than just this
so there are other ways to
create presentations i hope that's i
hope that answers your question
uh does it support bibtex uh citation i
already answered that
is there a reason a release date for
rstudio 1.2 i answered that
usually i have to create slides with the
company's standard design is there a way
for our markdown to accommodate
powerpoint templates um yes their
templates are a big
feature in our in powerpoint
rendering powerpoint presentations and
you can do that from
the the reference dock that is
here in the reference dock
and i would point you to the document
the help documentation online
can you customize diff um different
slides differently like a two content
layout for one slide
and another layout for another slide so
you have
these are the four layouts i think this
is a good question actually
um these are the these are the
two layouts for content slides and these
are the only two layouts that you have
now you can modify these to be you know
top and bottom side by side big and
small but these are the only two that
you have
and the way you use this one is you
specify um
column names or columns and columns look
something like
like this and the way you specify the
other one is not to use columns
so those are the two options today maybe
we'll have more options in the future
uh please submit your feedback we always
love to hear from our people
from our customers like what they think
is useful
can you embed vba code that is a dark
dark question and i'm just going to move
on how to
break flex table data frames into
different slides
[Music]
i'm not sure what a flex table is
so if you're if you're there
follow up with me or add another
question at
another follow-up so i know what a flex
table is
um is it possible to have more than four
templates
no just the four layouts today but we
appreciate the feedback and
maybe we can add some more in the future
can i email you
for other specific questions i have yes
i would go on to
for other follow-up i'd go on to
community.rtstudio.com
and i would um yeah i'm on there
and other there yeah and and yiway's on
there
um and multiple people are on there that
couldn't address these types of
questions so please
look for us on community.rtstudio.com
will you create a repository for sharing
powerpoint templates that can be used
with our markdown for making these
presentations yeah you know i
that's not a bad suggestion i i thought
about that um
there's a number of other issues our
studio that are kind of like that where
you know maybe you need a collection of
css templates
or you need a collection of add-ins
that are really useful uh some
powerpoint templates
i think it's i think it's pretty
reasonable question my best
suggestion right now is check out the
github repo that
i i pointed to earlier
it's this powerpoint
and this has a number of templates
already inside of it that you can use
okay uh yeah so we don't have a 1.2
release date for you today
for the finer grain control i recommend
the officer package yes yes so and that
that that's exactly right if you
want fine grain control where everything
is
the images are placed exactly where you
want it to be and size and layouts are
complex
and you've got other things going on in
that slide
by all means use an r package or do it
by hand there are markdown keep in mind
that
our markdown format is really used for
creating reproducible documents that you
can collaborate on and do data science
with
and it they're used to output into
multiple output formats not just
powerpoint
but to word html pdf and many more
i think that's a good place to pause i i
really appreciate the questions and
um really appreciate the attendance
thanks everyone
[Music]